surexcités
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon chéri très très bien de voir des
choses la taille pareille date fin de
choses à nous raconter plein de choses
risquent de fouet en fait j'ai reçu
plein de messages hier soir pour un truc
qui s'est passé a tant parlé en fin de
chronique
ah oui franchement je veux dire sur mon
choc qui s'est produit ici même hier
soir c'est vraiment très rare c'est très
rare vous savez que c'est manifestement
un temps dans les émissions télévision
font le maximum pour obtenir de
l'audience mais font aussi maximum pour
offrir les plus beaux cadeaux pour les
téléspectateurs
et une fois de plus quelle émission
offre les cadeaux les plus incroyables à
la télé touche pas à mon père lui des
cadeaux de ses incroyables joue pour ça
tout de suite dans les amours il ya zéro
budget on peut gagner un superbe voyage
des appartements dans des meilleures
stations de ski qui ont été validés par
blues experts dans les 12 coups de midi
annonce des cadeaux dans la vitrine dure
plus longtemps qu'une émission entière
de ces que de la télé via les séjours au
ski pour 4 était parfait oui se borne à
super combi l'appareil à raclette la
bibliothèque les séries platines vinyles
et puis bien sûr la voie
alors n'oubliez pas les paroles à
maestro déjà remporté une somme
équivalente au pib de l'ouzbékistan
[Musique]
au centre
le séjour au ski c'est bien la vitrine à
114 mais 337 euros
c'est sympa gagné 205 16000 euros juste
pour chanter du début de soirée de
l'image c'est cool mais non des pmp en
cadeaux ont fait bien plus fort regardez
le cas de l'incroyable qu'on avait gagné
lundi
au dessus ça servira plus longtemps je
vais te dire tu vas plus aux toilettes
quand royal je suis techniquement c'est
à vous apporter 200 paquets j'sais pas
comment la fac et par an c'est quoi ces
100 à 200 paquets mais apparemment d'un
spécial rouleau parents taxis
mais c'est vrai qu'il lui il fait
tellement chic et qui connaît tout ça au
bénin je travaillais sur l'émission
j'allais travailler ensemble et d une
fois de plus voilà c'est celui qui
travaille alors le chercher il s'affale
du ski travail de rouleau semaine sa
part énorme parce que l'épaisseur du
papier
merci ges le cynisme et c'est fou c'est
pas qu'on va le faire un débat sur ça
mais c'est vrai quoi vous vous allez
utiliser pas de papiers pas mais ça fait
deux rouleaux semaines la moyenne des
français utilisent ces feuilles ennemis
non feuilles et demi par par web alors
ça dépend parce que moi je fais suer sur
de papier a4
vous devez être le genre tire toujours
les 50 dans les mains et tout ça c'est
ça vous juste sur vous êtes me faire
chier longtemps
enfin parler mais parce que mathieu
alors oui il vient seulement deux fois
par semaine en touche pas à mon pote
parce que le résultat il prépare des
documentaires sur l'astronomie
déconstruit najoua fatick où la
croissance économique dans les pays de
l'ex urss
non je déconne il peut parler
documentaire sur la vie de céline dion
et rené la taupe c'est juste tout
simplement ce qu'il fait et comme il
vient rarement ici il est tellement
content qu'il n'a que des mots très
gentil envers ses camarades il soyez
alors vraiment soyez attentifs
soit c'est peut-être de fierté
soixantaine de méchanceté soit c'était
d'excéder moi je suis fan de mathieu
alias mois bo est méchant
[Musique]
mais très méchant avec son double
féminin kelly mais dominique
[Musique]
regardez comme il est excédé regardez
moi c'était extraordinaire de plaider
coupable mais ce n'est que le cahier le
plus méchant c'est bien sûr benjamin
castaldi méchant mais toujours
respectueux quand même vous quel était
votre rêve qu'on vous équipe qui vous
dit quoi mathieu vous rencontrez métier
est marqué ce qu'elle doit au moins
béton alors là métal et le bac
ouais ouais bah c'est un connard
alors est comment il n'a rien au bungee
karkwa vous allez toujours petit par
rapport à régler selon la carrière bat à
[Applaudissements]
les matches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va parler oui mais oui je veux tu dis
ça extrêmement courtois avec toi mon
cher et très gentil est ce que quand tu
as besoin de moi ce que je suis toujours
là jour toujours
voilà vous êtes pardonne toutes les
semaines avec des années maintenant il
m'a offert un cadeau le premier en 15
ans c'est vrai il faut faire un jambon
fromage voiture c'est vrai il avait
chargé du ces pour moi 80 quand même
j'avais besoin d'être motorisé ya deux
semaines jeudi benjamin tu fais ce que
tu veux mais je t'amène stora mais c'est
vrai alors c'est bon à savoir si vous
faites taxi après les rumeurs
si vous avez besoin que vous amènent
quelque part que si j'adore conduire
bonjour je pense que j'aurais été
chauffeur de taxi au chauffeur rumeurs
si j'avais pas faire une beauté
j'adore discuter avec les gens conduire
vivre quoi vivre avec un grand v j'ai
reçu une petite amende et oui abc fait
tout est réglé je sais pas ce que cet
abruti
je lui prêtais une voiture il s'est fait
flasher c'est pas vrai nous km vous
inquiétez pas je sais je sais que bien
là mais cette façon j'aurais pris
directement à la source avec harry
[Applaudissements]
l'autre chose et il ya eu 1 milliard
dans les milieux andraz milliards dont
je suis le principal fautif c'est vrai
c'est vrai on en parle pendant un
instant juste après avoir terminé avec
mathieu de langues il ya quelques
semaines
sa vie a basculé série grâce à vous
parce qu'une malédiction s'est levé il
va enfin animé sur ces vides le fameux
prime chez oui on en train de travailler
sur les rues financer entre m'a tuer et
moi avec les équipes mathieu on va le
proposer prochainement je pense que tu
vas y avait vraiment une co animation
non c'est une co animation on est très
proche c'est pas vrai ce que je dis mais
avec vous n'aurez pas à dire bonjour et
au revoir
bien sûr vous faites bonjour au revoir
moi je n'ai aucun dégoût franchement
c'est les mois à venir et c'est vous qui
dirait bonjour c'est vous qui dira au
revoir fait parce que j'explique aux
téléspectateurs c'est vrai qu'il ya des
couennes il m'a fait je raconte à
nouveau ce qui se passe c'est vraiment
c'est les coulisses de la télé chez que
vous adorez ça souvent qu'il ya deux
animateurs qui présentent ensemble il ya
une histoire d'ego énorme ça veut dire
que quand voilà quand par exemple il ya
sur la ferme célébrités il ya deux
animateurs quand sur santé moi de là il
ya deux animateurs l'important c'est
celui qui va dire bonjour
parce que celui qui dit bonjour c'est
celui me lauria cas le leader c'est
quand même ce livre la clef numéro un
alors entre les animateurs c'est une
guerre pas possible je vous lis voilà
pour savoir qui va dire bonjour moi je
vous le dit mon mathieu je vous
laisserai des bonjours tabac il dira que
ça
et c'est vrai qu'on a on a plain exemple
moi je me rappelle de christophe
dechavanne et laurence boccolini je suis
répond c'est pas qui est numéro un en
faire grand entre les deux mine de rien
voilà oui il ya même des animateurs qui
font compter avec le logiciel word le
nombre de mots elle est sûre ça me donne
encore plus de mots et il ya d'autres
animateurs dont je tairai lent qui
déplace la marque pour être plus près au
moment du bonjour sources qui n'ont pas
craqué lumière d'un canard il est arrivé
comme ça
il était dans l'ombre après away si vous
dirigez un animateur si je connais de
tf1 je vous jure que c'est vrai en fait
il a raison il comptait les mots il
ouvre la production connaît dit le
nantais il disait j'ai plus de j'ai
moins de mots que l'autre animateur
c'est pas possible différents série je
dirai jamais non
une autre est en elle la première lettre
à lui non non non c'est vrai elle même
alors ça s'est passé ainsi là j'avais
fait de l'auto mais il a des belles
boules match vous avez minutes 5 séries
ce qui veut dire effectivement vous
allez avoir un salaire de co animateur
on sait qu'au final vous serez
chroniqueur avant de revoir en détail sa
où le plaisir ça ou pas n'ont pas du
tout naturellement
regardez bien ça et après j'aurais
quelque chose quand même à vous dire en
détail votre victoire dans un instant
mais petit rappel de vos plus belles
défaites qui sont entrés dans la légende
comme france allemagne en 82 nuit
rappelez vous nous aideriez matthieu
delormeau était jusqu'à lors liberté
aussi vide louis avec des réactions de
déception meetic
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour moi caméra tuvalu mais une soirée
cutanées
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez animer après avec moi et je
vous le dis c'est plus tout à fait sûr
moi je dois vous le dire demain
ne manquez pas le jeu des vérités en
prime time sur ces 8
en direct c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire ne manquez pas le jeu des vérités
matthieu delormeau m'étais bien votre
capteur demain c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire on arrête là d'un
téléspectateur on en parlera demain afin
de vous verrez alors à demain et les
téléspectateurs j'espère qu'ils ne
seront pas aussi déçu que j'ai pu l'être
g ça peut être un ultimatum tel de
gaulle dans les années 60 et pas de
gauche parmi les partis ont du coup vous
verrai ça demain on cédric seguinel
prime avant d'en venir au drame d'hier
soit on sait que le rêve de cirer les
menaces et de récupérer la bac qui l'a
offerte à fatou alors qui aura jamais de
mariage sans le sait mais le rêve de
matthieu delormeau c'était animé un
prime sur ces huit donc je le disais
donc une malédiction a pris fin 19
décembre dernier et je m'en moque on
analyse la soirée de sa victoire
on va commencer avec eux vraiment cessé
façon de nous éblouir par ses
interventions sur les médias qu'est-ce
que tel alors qu'aucun lien n'avait pas
voir mais choisir la destination
pour convaincre tout le monde sait que
c'est lui qui l'ont remporté ce prime
mathieu c'est ce vendredi
et accessoirement première dame de
l'animateur
[Musique]
on apprit qu isabelle était meilleur en
voyant ce camp d'anecdotes
9 c'est le prime et pour mathieu c'est
sur le prime et dans la neuve plus rien
ni personne ne le fera changer d'avis
[Musique]
tout est bon pour mathieu claude fini
match le loser place à mathieu le
présentateur
[Applaudissements]
donc c'est la revanche de mathieu on n'a
toujours pas compris sa façon de
célébrer sa victoire
[Musique]
oui
manquez pas le freiner
et demain et la moulasse aussi la drogue
est bien entendu de leurs mots nazis
moules ou mais si vous aimez faire
passer une nuit horrible c'est pas
demain c'est l'eau chaude des guérites
et ce sera demain ce sera à 21h sur ces
huit venait mettez votre capteur et on
verra si vous dites america bac c'est de
l'entité il promeut ce rêve français
vous serez face à vos responsabilités et
faire revenir le tout leur jeu vous dire
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour vous ouais
et je t'écris vraiment déçu je vais vous
dire pourquoi je crois que matthieu
delormeau
il y avait des boîtes et je sais pas
pourquoi vous avez pris la 9
ces deux-là montage c'est un montage moi
je vais te démonter la glace on verra ça
demain vous verrez non non non non mais
ne dit rien c'est eh oui la boîte de
kelly et v2 région verra ça demain
on a toutes les images matthieu
delormeau aura de solution demain où il
avoue tout et 21h ou bien on mettra face
à ses responsabilités face aux français
face à vous merci
mathieu pour l'instant aujourd'hui
passer une bonne émission
mais on verra ça demain 14 ans
ça serait beaucoup mieux pour le public
pas du tout cyril est une femme kelly à
temps pour virer de caunes panafieu
[Musique]
il parlait de l'eau dans l'autre chose
c'est prévu bah ouais tu verras ça
d'alors pour finir il est temps d'en
venir au chaud qui s'est produit en
direct hier soir sur ce plateau la
semaine alors j'ai montré à quel point
si vous étiez un nouvel homme en 2020 à
apaiser calme nuancé est vrai tout ça
grâce à une nouvelle méthode de
relaxation qui consiste en une chose
balancez absolument tout ce qui lui
passe par la tête sans aucun filtre
c'est une technique cgt scoop à la télé
ce week-end vous avez raison c'est ce
qui arrive est la vérité mais bien sûr
la vérité que comme de 23 comme demain
soir combien de langues ou alors ça
arrive une nouvelle fois isabelle
morini-bosc seuil annuel va lui proposer
de faire un exercice de relaxation quand
il croit qu'il est hors antenne
sauf que toute la france entendu ce
grand moment c'est la méthode baba zen
[Musique]
alors si l'on se souvient du jour vous
allez donner un conseil bien être à
isabelle morini-bosc ya quelques
semaines qu hier isabelle faisait une
expérience scientifique pour disperser
du poivre dans l'eau avec un doigt ce
qu'on fait tous les jours bien sûr pour
disperser rapidement du poivre dans de
l'eau avec son doigt il faut auparavant
remettre ce dernier dans son oreille a
longtemps déjà que grâce à la méthode la
base n cyril vous êtes très calme
il lui mais non parce que normalement ça
doit être vraiment bardot pas entendu
l'expérience en td ne fonctionne pas
alors au moment de vérifier en vidéo ce
qu'on aurait dû voir cyril lâche un
nouveau conseil bien-être à isabelle
conseil qui normalement aurait dû être
orientés mais en fait on a tous entendu
bakchich voilà voyez laurent tri-nations
ils voient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la personne qui a dit ça parlait de
l'animal jusqu'à là deux chambres
isabelle voilà et merci et j'adore vos
chats vous les embrasser bien entendu il
y en a un qui s'appelle répulsion et
rectangles et drôle tertio et rectum à
bout les embrassant merci je me suis
permis de dire ça bien entendu on va
vérifier à chaque achat
[Applaudissements]